all right blue light cap podcast in here
Troy Ave is in the building
got his great baby straight new album is
out new album is out absolutely
uh how is everything man you are wrapped
up in a lot of [__] there's a lot of
back and forth on the internet right now
I just saw my son just dropped a new
record today did you see that no I don't
I don't I don't end insane
like
trash you feel me like when we don't
stop to pick the coins up off the floor
it'll make no sense it's like really
trash I've I'm I can honestly see how I
go the rest of my life without
hearing a song from a taxi Robert
you feel me well you put you put a
record out about him all right yeah he's
no I I just talked about him being a
taxi robber when I make records this is
a fact I actually Rob taxi drivers and
he stole a hundred and three dollars in
total uh walkie-talkie in a gold ring
and he did seven years in jail for that
so I wouldn't listen to the music of
somebody whose life is worth 15 a year
it made no sense and I suggest you don't
either so you don't even unless you just
like consume a change so if somebody
disses you you're not even like let me
just take a listen well I never like
what the [__] am I listening to before
oh I'm not like one of these when I tell
you the type of music I listen to I
listen to
Soul music I listen to Tupac I listen to
um
pz like it's different I don't just be
listening to rap just listen to rap I
don't give a [__] about that I'd rather
when I sit in my pool in my house I'm
listening to [__] you know put 80s
dance hits on like Scarface
I just if someone if someone put a whole
song to get together about me I'm at
least listening to it once I can't
listen to it because there's no there's
nothing they can do
I don't have no skeletons in my closet
can't nobody pull nothing like I'm I'm
super authentic not to say that like so
God whatever I'm just saying like
authentic as [__] is probably living in
my truth so something that somebody's
gonna say is nothing that you can come
out and say to discredit me this person
did this to me before like how somebody
could say Chino got wedgied and cut by
boxing bar and oh now it's a big thing
or might sound you a taxi ride but you
try to get it straight from the incident
now your activists know you're a taxi
robber and a hater you know what I'm
saying so what are they gonna say about
your ass I'm a successful businessman I
own Lamborghinis and other phones I got
13 properties like I own uh trucking
companies I mean I got a restaurant
businesses like what are you gonna say
about me I don't have a whole baby moms
like what's what's the [__] you gonna
put unless you're gonna make up some
[__] like or have an opinion that most
people don't share so what the [__] am I
there's never gonna be no shocking [__]
that they gonna say about me that I
don't know about myself and it's not
offensive they're gonna try to make
something up and use it in an offensive
way I don't consume [__] bro I don't
eat junk food well I think like um a
couple of things to clear up because I
do think that now that obviously
the trial and you know everything is
passed you could you could say the most
part for the most part I gotta go to
jail for no [__] I ain't safe for no
[__] reason
let's see It'll be up to the judge
maybe a year maybe longer maybe maybe
less maybe the judge would be like you
know you ain't been in no trouble before
this or after this so you know you it
was an isolated incident a jealous
bottom feeder predicate felon bum ass
[__] hater that you know [__]
gasoline on the fire so well I think um
because kind of helped me walk me
through this because
taxton's lawyer his name is redstone we
address people probably
listen the guy's in jail you won he's in
jail it doesn't matter Bing is dead uh
it ain't no you know what I'm saying
like so it's levels his levels to
winning and [__] you feel for sure I had
lost custody in my kids I had to fight
for that I had to pay over 200 000 loyal
fees
yes all of these type of [__] that I had
to go through my career was crippled
right like it ain't you can't you can't
I'm I'm kicking a [__] scumbag
cockroaches when they down you feel me
I'm stepping them it's gonna be guts on
the bottom of my shoe his name is
redstone he wrote a letter to the judge
and his whole defense was that he didn't
kill Banger choyab did it wrestle for
the gun and Troy have shot his friend so
he's a [__] rat and he's a [__]
cockroach and he's a bottom feeder and
we need to remove haters from the
[__] Community we need to remove them
they need to be treated with the same
disdain as we do [__] snitches that
do crowns with their homies and turn
around and flip on them as we do it
child molesters as we do with rapists
all these type of people because hate is
a Cancer and that [__] spews over to
other people well that's what I was
gonna say so I've this you know I think
that the one thing about this gentleman
is he does have a lot of Industry
friends right and so me being somebody
who was actually friends with Banga
right the thing had a lot of love for
you
um
I never was like
free dude [__] that like dude killed my
boy you know what I'm saying like I
personally like it is what it is I'm not
in the situation I wasn't there but like
um I think that the the I do think that
the reason why you're not necessarily
going
through a lot of the backlash that like
um maybe a guy like six nine went
through is because the situation
at least how it's been explained is
you just cleared your name up after a
lawyer essentially wrote a letter
pinning everything on you well it wasn't
so much a lawyer it was so much him you
can't do anything without your lawyer's
approval you have to give your latest
information his lawyers is not coming up
with alleged crimes that we was involved
in that's him being a goddess in the
know of Street things you know what I'm
saying it's not his lawyer is not coming
up with this info so they wrote a letter
to the judge but even before that the
whole defense was that you know I
shooting on camera right you know what
I'm saying like just just Coney [__]
that we're not going for and as far as
like me and six nine is totally
different because
six nine is it it was an active gang
member when you win gang [__] that [__]
is in the streets you keep that [__] in
the streets I don't care if somebody
rapes your mother you go kill them oh
you have whatever happens to them right
you it don't be no police [__] involved
oh my street business I kept in the
streets I got shot when I was 15. you
never heard about it it's in the streets
I barely don't even rap about it right I
got shot in my head on Christmas Day
yeah I was there the detectives was at
my best side I ain't have nothing to say
because we kept that in the streets this
[__] is the internet this [__] is the
same thing that with this is like a
stalker somebody who would tweet
somebody 780 times over a five-year
period this is craziness it's like the
person who killed John Lennon the the
the [__] who killed Selena even though
she wasn't a stalker she was an
assistant right like this is a totally
different situation you feel me this
started in the public and you don't
never allow nobody to just say I'ma
crash out throw my life away and I'm
taking you down down with me now get the
[__] over me you go off that bridge
yourself don't yeah get off my body
right right right right right and I do
think too like you know you said let her
aside that it was a situation that was
but I do think the letter kind of like
at least optically kind of like is like
hey
definitely you know what I mean like you
want me to just like go with what this
letter says we want me to hold myself
down you feel me yeah you wanna you
wanna play it fair you wanna you wanna
play fit and inside that you know I
would even let somebody determine the
Rules of Engagement the rules of the
game you know what I'm saying which it
happened but then it's like wait hold on
it's we both in the ring box and this
person took the gloves off and you know
I mean they they spray some [__] in my
eye what the [__] I'm supposed to do I
wanted to talk to you because
um and the real ones are seeing it if
you look at the public opinion even with
people like my son and generally these
nuts the taxi robber he'll put up a post
and people will be under his comments
like [__] you talking about I have a
real [__] you bugging he did what most
rappers talk about doing you want him to
take the murder of his friend you want
to take attempted murder on somebody
that shot him and he took the gun from
like people in the comments right even
when Chino put up a post like these guys
got to make their comments limited when
you say Channel yeah you know exactly
who he is I love Mano man I was just in
uh Emmanuel doesn't love you you love
him he doesn't love you it may not solid
he's a good guy what is he done good I
mean
well that's how you judge a man you
judging me as character by their actions
but you and may not have great records
together you guys you've done favors for
him and I've and I've done records and
I've carried I mean it was on your album
too no he's only he wasn't in New York
City [__] no no what was the record oh
no I'm thinking of Prodigy I'm thinking
of The Prodigy when I do albums I'm
meticulous with them [__] no no I'm
thinking of that yeah
people who I admire on New York City the
album not just whoever is you never
admired Mano ever
I supported because he was from from
Brooklyn right and he was coming up I'm
always support I'm I I show love right
you know what I'm saying always I show
love that's how I'm always show love so
I bought this album when it came out it
was trash you know what I'm saying that
was trash though
well there's only one that I was the
first album was great his first time
come on no no that I'm on Atlanta here
we go here we gonna go with the cats
the first album was great right his
debut album on Atlantic was crazy the
first album was great it was great is it
better than he had a record on there
called Soldier I bet she was it is not
better than him and I'm not even gonna
say classic like outcasts and [__] like
that since you say an album
no I think this is one of the greatest
albums ever okay see you don't got a
bunch of albums over here
um now I got some here
it's better than this but I'm not going
I'm not I think it's better by end he
could never do nothing better than I
think Manos if he got him is better than
that album from nas his first album
because he's put out other albums
through Empire and [__] oh what bro his
first album was hard oh we got seriously
look into your uh we gotta look bro they
know his first album slept on you're the
only person saying that that's not true
you I'm telling you who you and him's
album is hard bro his first album it's
good it's taking so people get in the
comments yeah tell me your comments and
especially from New York my bandana
Soldier he has some [__] on that person
oh that's all right so if you call his
album great what would you call New York
City album if you had to rate them from
one attack I think it's a better album
but if you have I want to see how you
know I'm a huge fan of of New York City
I think that's your best album I want to
see
it you think major you haven't really
hate I win yet then um that's more of
everything but what
when you say great album if on a scale
of one to ten if New York City the album
was a 10 or whatever you want to call it
what would that album be because we got
a deal in facts here we're gonna bring
the facto show to my God [__] and we
only our opinions always based on facts
okay so what would be get rich or die
trying to be a 10 yeah absolute a lot of
things I won't
I'm gonna say like a 9.8 I'm I'm okay
get rich or die trying I got a personal
thing with like 50 Cent my favorite get
rich or die trying is a 10.
New York City the album for me is like a
like a Hard Eight okay and I think
maino's album's like a seven and a half
seven are you [__] me his first
album is fire bro let's go to Pitchfork
because Pitchfork actually just worked
they give people zeros that's a bunch of
[__] Williamsburg [__] weenies in
tight pants [__] writing albums oh
you say it's a great album because it
has red lights is it lyricism
truth
voice records
it was a good concept it started off
with him getting freed from jail I like
the album oh you want me to no no it's
objective I just want to know why your
opinions like that because I want it
because people have opinions why am I
why are like maino's first album yeah
like I went like I know I mean I don't
want to know anymore but I just I was
saying like your opinion like I think it
was I'll tell you why I Love YG album
his first album all my crazy he likes
the classic for sure that's what I'm
trying to say it's about an it's like a
9.2 when we say greats and Classics now
most people would tell you New York City
album is a classical amazing what I'll
do is classical new pop that's what most
people will tell you it was the classics
now
I'm not gonna toot my own on my new [__]
but I've never heard nobody say his [__]
was a classic and we got to be careful
with the titles that we give today well
I didn't say I didn't say classic I said
it was a great album though
what I mean great album so we have bad
albums good albums great albums
something else and then Classics or yeah
all right so it's made
it's a great album yeah we got two
levels above it it's made two levels
above it two levels below I just want
with hip-hop is too much gray areas like
when you see I mean it's all objective
this is also objective to like what I
serious people there's people who who
love Playboy cardi I don't agree with
them well but but that's the thing it's
subjective we have if we have a uh if we
have a grading system and a formula
there's no formula because everyone's
grading system and formula is different
that's what I'm trying to say that's
what we need if we have a great somebody
some people might say like I might be
like yo
obviously is my favorite player I know
Jordan is better but Iverson is my goat
you know what I'm saying exactly but I
can say why okay Jordan is better for
these reasons you know what I'm saying
no I'm not the same way I feel about
like a lot of rap [__] I could be like
Pusha T is in my top five or maybe my
top like eight push it t you'd probably
top
see now you saying overall if I'm
talking about drugs
my personal favorites Pusha T's in my
top ten yeah hands down
if you were to have me put together like
the not bootleg cab10 push is not in the
top ten okay so you mean but I'm putting
him high as [__] on my [__] right
that's right he's right there you know
what I'm saying I got Tupac up there I
just got into a [__] argument with
Jim Jones that went viral over him
saying Pusha T was in top 50. I was like
you're [__] crazy yeah I heard it but
I heard about him saying it on like top
50. that's crazy it's a wild wild
statement what's up y'all bootleg Kev
here man got to tell you about our new
sponsors at King Palm baby got a shout
out to them and we're welcoming them
into the new family man of course uh we
treat all of our partners at the bootle
cat podcast like family shout out to
King Palm man if you all don't know
about King Palm they are the leaders in
the smoking industry when it comes to
their tobacco-free blunt wraps no
nicotine no tobacco just good old leaves
all right yeah that's right um and look
their product that I love are these
right here now these right here are the
pre-rolled tips you just stuff them with
your your herb your cannabi that you get
from a Hardin and uh
they got these terpene and flu infused
uh tips now what they are is you put
your weed in there all right you hit the
[__] little pinch on that thing and
you could just burst the flavor now
these are the red reins which is like an
energy drink flavor obviously they got
the Strawberry Shortcake which is also
gas now this is what's dope too there's
just so many lines of these rolls uh
shout out to the leaf tubes you can get
these blueberry these big blue grape
Fusion joints so much you can get man so
many products uh check out your local
7-Eleven your local smoke shop all that
but you could also go to kingpom.com
right now and get everything online
delivered right to your door for half
off 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg that's right shout out to King
Palm man we're talking about essential
smoking uh when it comes to like just
getting that Clean Smoke it's not too
harsh or organic you ain't putting
nothing crazy in your lungs you know
what I'm saying shout out to King pong
no tobacco no nicotine
just straight look and I gotta shout
them out too because
can we take just take a a good look at
this
you know we got multiple sized King Palm
hitters over here
I think right there is like a goddamn
Jesus
that's a [__] boy right there you
know what I mean shout out to King Palm
that's a king pong Leaf right there
stuff with some fire some fire all right
so look right now you're gonna want to
go to uh kingpom.com uh use that promo
code bootleg get half off whatever you
need smoking accessories Leafs some of
these awesome uh pre-rolls that they
have that you just stuff your stuff in
stuff your stuff in you know what I mean
um kingpom.com 7-Eleven your local smoke
shop all that make sure you follow them
online at King Palm and check them out
speaking of stuff that you're stuffing
shout out to my bookie man my bookie you
already know mybookie.ag I'm riding with
the Phoenix Suns God damn it them Sons
going all the way uh if you are like me
and you like to uh you know put a
friendly wager on some sports
which I do a lot I've been using my
bookie for about 10 years now uh you can
go do the same thing right now now this
is what's dope about my book you go to
mybookie.ag it's the online sports book
not only is it an online sports book
they got the Blackjack they got the
whole Casino situation craps roulette
whatever you're into you could play it
right at mybookie.ag and if you use the
promo code bootleg when you sign up
bootleg you'll see it down below
[Music]
when you sign up you'll get that first
deposit bonus now get a new account
mybookie.ag when you sign up bootleg is
the promo code first deposit bonus up to
a thousand dollars you put in money they
give you money it's that simple all
right there's so many ways you can win
money of course they got NHL right now
the playoffs are happening in hockey if
you're from [__] Canada and you care
about a terrible boring sport also
basketball NBA playoffs are booming
right now put all the money on the
future for the sunset with a
championship thank me later I got Sons
versus Celtics in the uh finals also
baseball
another atrociously boring sport but a
great sport to gamble on all right so
what you're going to want to do go to
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
right now and get uh your first deposit
bonus unlocked speaking of unlocked
unlock your [__]
go to bluetooth.com right now
it is summertime if you're dealing with
elect erectile dysfunction Ed if you
will maybe you got stress at work maybe
you're tired of looking at the same
chick
maybe you just need a little pep in your
step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits and uh it has the same
active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it I promise you that
Bluetooth also is uh incredible because
not only does it come in the blue
chewable flavor with the same active
ingredient as vibrancy house but it also
has a mint chewable flavor which is the
same active ingredient as Levitra all
right all this if you're questioning I
don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this [__] work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com because it's going to get
delivered right to your house they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars
shipping that's it the Bluetooth come
into your house no awkward doctor's
appointments no awkward doctor's visits
it's all online
bluetooth.com thank me later thank me
later let's get back to the interview
um no so
we we we went on a mano tangent Channel
his name is chano when I was I just came
from the Vegas fight with uh uh Javonte
Davis and Ryan Garcia I'm on the floor
seats you know what I said there's no
haters it cost money to be a hater or an
enemy or Optima okay I'm on the floor
seats I'm walking around the whole [__]
I walk the yard people yelling say no
say no yo Troy Ave keep doing what the
[__] you doing everybody celebrities I
love what you I'm introducing myself to
people who I didn't think know me yo man
help me understand like that I'll [__]
with you what's the origin of the of the
of the Maino thing it could go watch
documentaries so listen I saw a video
where you were on your Instagram
where you were claiming that maina was
wearing the same Cuban Link I didn't
claim that he he he claimed the people
claimed that the people claim that the
people winning his comments and said he
had a change
but to me
when you're pointing out just the like
Cuban link right
some of the things you pointed out that
were like yo look you still got the same
Cube I never said anything that's the
people yeah but that's to say to say
like one Cuban Link and another Cuban
Link are the same but we're not so it's
kind of strange he's talking about the
Jesus Piece actually whatever he pulled
out in the back of that minute right
back but that's different from I saw a
post of yours where you were talking
about
look he's wearing that same chain link
without the piece I've never I've I've
never said that that's a fact I know
what I say I've never said that there's
a documentary a short that shows
everything who's putting out who's
putting it together these are you
putting together these dogs the people
man the people I got de facto Show
podcast even the title of our daily me
as Batman everybody knows Batman is
Bruce Wayne he has beautiful women he
lives luxurious houses jobs nice cars
and there's a bunch of bottom feet of
haters the penguin Bane Joker that's
what all these people are so let me ask
you this Troy because if people put that
together so I feel like Batman hey yo
facto show real one viewers I need y'all
make me a couple like that with all
these haters and he did it do you feel
like you are at times participating in
unnecessary drama for someone ever
that's as rich as you are and for
someone who's been through as much as
you've been through well that's all a
part of perspective
listen like like you got someone tried
to kill you on Christmas obviously the
shooting that happened that we all know
about you know what I'm saying
I feel like
you're you're you're kind of like
this the court case got wrapped up and
you just kind of Dive Right into a whole
lot of [__] drama and I just feel
like
well I'm gonna tell you that that's your
perspective not really thoroughly
knowing me before music it should happen
to me that you see is just highlighted
now because I'm entertaining and I got
some Fame and a little bit of celebrity
but I really come from
the streets and trying to make it out of
that it was hard for me to get to even
this point of that point of you knowing
me I've been through way worse [__]
before I got to that point of you
knowing me right so now that you see
this and it's highlighted it just it's
blowing up more but I haven't been
through as far as what I was where I'm
coming from I'm doing pretty good not
I'm not talking about financially I'm
talking about as far as things with
people when you one of those guys if I
was like I've always been like a popular
person and I've always worked like from
high school whatever there's been people
that didn't like me for certain reasons
when I got in the street I'm getting
more money than people I'm driving next
to cars they ain't like me for certain
reasons reasons and [__] happens in here
and you got to protect yourself but at
this point
saying that do I think I'm getting
unnecessary stuff it's all a matter of
perspective it's like it does does um
there's [__] a full-time Champion
like Klay Thompson have to show his
rings to somebody somebody can say clay
you're above that why are you doing that
it's all a matter of perspective you
feel what I'm saying there's Kobe the
the Black Mamba have to go off and play
Kyrie Irving for talking [__] like for
I'm a champ I don't got to play you with
this Olympic [__] so because it's all a
matter of perspective right I don't I
think that with me I would be too I
would be above and I've never have
started any issues with people but
sometimes when people come to me and
again I don't want you or any viewers to
only look at or lock into the issues
that I do take on because mad issues
come across my desk and I [__] ignore
them right so if I ignore 20 issues or
people taking shots at me and this song
and trying to uh destroy in my character
if I know that and I choose to but you
know what [__] these 20 people who they
they're roach guts on the bottom of my
shoe let me deal with with these other
four or five people
and I think that's my that's That's My
Prerogative to do that you know what I'm
saying it's like God [__] it and I maybe
I'll deal with those other people later
maybe I won't but perspective is is
saying if you have a perspective it all
is about where you from your experiences
with life and whatever for sure look
Jay-Z was
top of the top he didn't have to go at
us he was already ahead of him he didn't
have to do many things that he's done he
didn't have to do that
I'm from New York I noticed he he got to
the point he said yeah now I'ma really
step on his neck that's when Nas started
putting out weak music you know I mean
no disrespecting knowledge but it wasn't
like it was a right after nostradam and
then he came back with that still Maddie
[__] like what the [__] you talking
about this is me so my thing is is like
you talked about like the new album and
how it's like one of your best bodies of
work you think it's your best body of
work it is my best body work because
I've been through
like New York City the album took my
whole life to make that right that it
made you without a deal more so major
what I did was album I always wanted to
make because it's a combination in a
combination of everybody I grew up
you're listening to him wanting to hear
him and rap and all my favorite rappers
I played Fat Joe in that [__] I had 50
Cent on this right every pushing teeth
five like whoever everybody was on this
[__] Nori Prodigy you know what I'm
saying I made that album because I had
the ability and access to people Raekwon
right Raekwon was my favorite rappers
for sure you feel me so that's that
album New York City was album that I did
for the city
that can't that that'll be one of my
Greatest Albums Of Classic Albums to
people from New York City because I did
that for the city right I took my shine
and my highlight and I sacrificed for
the city I wasn't trying to appeal to
people everywhere else because I'm like
my city needs this I'm a sack I'm not
gonna jump on the south beat like
everybody else is doing just to try to
get on I'm a sacrifice and I'm Gonna
Stand ten toes down and rep for my city
but this album did hate our one this is
me going through my most tragic time in
life going through the lowest points in
life you know what I'm saying like like
total in the public eye and then
overcoming that and this [__] is like it
ain't just dead hater I want is there
hater we want anybody that overcame some
[__] if you woke up this morning and you
got some level of success in these
people hating on you and you still
breathing still carrying on it's dead we
won real [__] and ain't nobody in
hip-hop history that could has gone
through the [__] that I went through
lived survived and then been able to put
an album out with it do you think that
at times
the
spectacle of some of these beasts you're
wrapped up in
might take away from people like diving
into the album no [__] I think it's the
opposite [__] no I I don't I'm gonna be
honest I don't even take the time like
like I said I'm I'm one of the most
um authentic
enroll
artists to where I don't pick and choose
my battles I don't say oh come on guys
this might be not politically correct
right now let's not do this like I take
the battles as they come if I have time
for it you know what I'm saying so like
I even think did I win has allowed
people to see how lyrical Troy Ave is I
mean real life lyrical like um um since
you [__] like writing letters here go
one dear hater I won I'm a boss you a
bum like the the breakdown of that
this you know hip-hop
on that album I said since you [__]
like writing letters here goes one get a
pen
I write this as a free man made paid
half a mill out the pen
I'm out of your league don't pretend
bowling on point like a pin I sat many
months you wrote To The Judge soon as
you walked in Mr Collins and his
Entourage me doing a lot of shootings a
recent went outside the New York City
Club pursue them and that was people
suing trying to take all our stack got
attempted murder because I took the gun
from him and bust back these ain't no
made up raps I'm paraphrasing the facts
I'm the king of the underground he's
just an underground rat I rose up above
the road and stay trying to pull your
boy back with a cold showed in cold the
hand whoever reaching gets smacked smear
that
URL
I'm a w i and Lambos and Bentleys where
I dwell it's a mansion for sale I bought
that you just bought to a cell a real
[__] lives on while a fake one dies in
jail
I took the actual
Court documented statement from redstone
and put it in a song and made it lyrical
Mr Collins and his Entourage it's not
made up [__] right that people do people
make up words bowling on point like a
pin everybody there's no bars taking off
smirk URL I'm a w URL I'm a w i n Lambos
i n w i n Win you didn't get that stop
it don't do that [__] you're doing this
I'm a w i and Lambos and Bentley's why I
dwell it's a mansion for sale talking
about where I dwell I bought that you
just bought to a cell like these are the
shits that people won't get or
understand so now when you got the light
on you and [__] oh oh you got more eyes
on you people like oh [__] I ain't no
chill apples that dope and I see it I
got a podcast called facto show I see it
in fact because now I put out old
records that I put out a year ago and
[__] yo this is crazy yo I put
it out a year ago you didn't see it then
right it's cool you wasn't paying
attention
you late to the party but come on in now
enjoy it we we always we showing love we
spreading love and destroying hey let me
ask you this man obviously uh rest in
peace the whole vein man um who passed
away last year from heart attack
um
do you after when you lose somebody like
that
did it make you regret any of the stuff
that you put into the air about hovane
no I didn't because I I put nothing but
facts into the above which you don't
what you don't know about vain
you don't know the real you don't know
the real him and just like a lot of
people don't I was on math half a
podcast and I had to correct somebody
they were saying yeah and I'll be
awesome man did you do anything for for
his kids what what you don't know was I
gave him the name of
which you might not know is that I
brought him into the industry you made I
know that okay now
what you don't know is your relationship
with him comes through me 100 right what
you don't know is he didn't [__] with
you
it was me saying nah I [__] with Kev you
bugging but Jose knew how to play the
game I like I said I'm real and uncut I
don't pretend to [__] with people when I
don't I don't if I [__] with you I
genuinely do if I don't I just don't
there's no beef no I'm personal I don't
he knows how to put on the smiling face
that's why I say hey you'll be at the
Forefront be the manager now did he grow
the [__] with you later on yeah like
hours and hours of conversations for the
last five years so now here go the thing
let me tell you when when the counseling
is real it's countless people who had
hours and hours of conversations with
him they ain't countless peoples who had
hours I was in conversation with me
because it is it's worth more it's not
just giving to anybody it's giving to
people who I genuinely cared for in
general so but the reason why I bring
that up is because obviously I'm gonna
tell you I don't regret anything that's
the truth
you're his kids Godfather correct yeah
one of them one of his kids Godfathers
and my thing is is when there's that
level of like love at a certain point
right because I think there was like a
certain point in time where you put out
like a almost like a podcast it was like
a 30 minute thing where you were talking
about what happened and you were talking
about Jose and I think it was a check on
the dope boy Cherry project yeah
um and it was like kind of like you
talking for like it was about a half
hour I was just talking about the whole
initial part of me meeting them because
like like I said I deal with facts I was
talking about how when I I got a a
management deal with Butch Lewis God
bless the day real man he put me on with
rap and they say yo I'm gonna give you
this much money a week and I said why
can you take some of that money out of
my money and give my partners uh K cash
in hovane which got nothing to do with
music I'm just putting them on we ride
around selling music yo can you give
them 300 a week each 600 now out of your
money but out of my money I did that
that's how I sacrificed for my people so
for somebody that I did that for they
owe me more than that for somebody I
helped get out the projects they owe me
more than that for somebody who I gave a
name to I put this this was a dream it
is I put them on with a dream I didn't
but it was managers that I could have
went with and and like most people do
they switch managers they diss the
people that they came up with I never
did that even with god with money knows
Chris Lighty I'm like yo listen
I'ma [__] with y'all but my dog gotta be
with me that's real loyalty when when
most managers be like well no it's only
me or nobody you know this from being in
the game but I'm like yo listen it's 20
but my dog who got no experience and
don't know [__] he got to be with me or
else I ain't [__] with you that's
real loyalty that most people won't do
and and for somebody that does that
they owe me more they owe me more than
that than to
have a we got an understanding of
um I got charged with four with four
counts of weapons possession attempted
murder and they was lingering the murder
of my friend Banger my real friend right
on over over my head I'm talking about
bangers my real man like when when he
come home from jail I'm bailing them out
we at the crib with a chef having [__]
there oh vane ain't there you feel me
it's a fact so my thing is is yeah I'm
saying they owe me more than that to
where if you and your guys right here I
don't know everybody's position but they
here he's doing his thing he's doing his
thing
but she said y'all riding around you get
caught with a gun illegally I don't know
the dynamic of your relationship but I
feel like
one of your guys should be like yo Kev
keep [__] going I'm gonna take this gun
charge I ain't gonna sit for long just
hold me down financially because if you
go to jail all this [__] stops right
real [__] so now imagine coming from the
street knowing that and now you into
music making more money and being more
successful and the game plan is uh yo
listen y'all [__] it nobody else help me
with no money for Bill no lawyer no
nothing it's cool I got that it's all I
need
I'm gonna fight this attempted murder
and I'm gonna fight this gun this other
gun charge y'all just fight the gun
charges I'm paying for the lawyer and
everything I didn't pay for a lawyer
with uh with hope before and beat it
John Stella my same attorney I had beat
a gun charge for him spanked it hey I
just need y'all to do that
all right bet I'll call Wolfie on the
phone hope said in court that yo if they
when they finally when they brought up
that they caught the guns in there in
court he said I'm gonna take the other
gun because that's what we do that's
what I did for him that's what I'm gonna
do for anybody in a higher position
that's holding us down you know what I'm
saying what's up guys hey uh if you are
watching this and it's April 20th 4 20
I'm gonna be hanging out at hardean
today
that's right put the flyer up The Rock
I'll be at hardeen um hanging out all
day today
um the craziest most just luxurious
illest dispensary in the world located
right in Las Vegas Nevada now Hardy in
Las Vegas they are our family they'd
sponsor the podcast I love those guys
dearly and when I say that it is the
best place I've ever walked into to buy
premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so what y'all need to do
is go follow them online hardeen
underscore Las Vegas follow them on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're gonna be doing a
lot of content in Vegas
live from Hardin they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope fly gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
that get that hard eating whiff smells
amazing so look make sure you go to
hardine uh if you're in Vegas get in
that Uber get in that cab as soon as you
touch down say take me to hardine the
taxi drivers the Ubi drivers they know
exactly where it is because it's the
hottest spot in Vegas they go take you
straight there you're gonna tell them I
sent you they're going to get you
situated real nicely all right Harding
underscore Las Vegas go show them some
love go to hardinglasvegas.com gotta
give a shout out to our oh geez my dogs
had Odd Socks baby they've been [__]
with us from day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butt-head socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead
oh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
otsoxofficial.com my first uh suggestion
would be get you a pair or a pack of the
Odd Socks Basics the black and the
whites those are my go-to's and then you
gotta [__] with some of these Big
Lebowski socks and they just got
Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got a [__] South Park
come on bro what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview so I guess for them to act
funny all of a sudden when it's time and
I hold the end of the bugging that ain't
100 to me I guess my thing is that's
like hoven's passed away like he's not
here anymore you know what I mean and
like well we spoke after that we spoke
after that we we spoke on multiple
occasions I've seen him and you know it
is what it is that don't take back the
facts so my thing is this is like you
know there's [__] that's online now that
like his kids are gonna have to grow up
and like you know when they look up
their pops on that [__] YouTube bro
it's it's the truth but my thing is
you don't regret anything that you said
about him
if I had made up stuff and I came up
with slander and [__] then cool but I
said [__] that was the truth they they
said I was on drugs he said I was
bugging he told somebody he had to get
away before he had to put hands on me
where in the [__] were we you put hands
on choice that don't [__] like these
are the narratives that they pushed so
that they wouldn't look crazy when
everybody's like well why did you leave
Ave why wasn't you there we come from if
you come somewhere with somebody you
leave with them you don't leave your
friends I don't give a [__] if you hear
shots in the other room and your peoples
went in that room to go to the bathroom
you run the [__] there you don't walk
out the door I got to get out of here
you go see and make sure they good
that's where we come from and when the
pressure was on they didn't stand on
that so if his kids if my kids got to
see [__] online about me that shoe they
gotta see it the [__] lady who uh
said Emmett Till looked at her just died
people don't give a [__] right she
should have never said that [__] the
[__] could burn in hell good riddance I
just think like you taking it it's all
about perspective it's all about how you
feel and you can't ever pacify
somebody's feelings cause I was there
Ground Zero of the Betrayal that's like
me saying if something happens with you
and my wife can't leave it alone well I
think that's Ground Zero again you talk
about perspective I think like talking
to him there's like a different
perspective on my way his you got you
but then you have the truth bro I only
deal in the truth I'm telling you you
don't know this person
everything that I said about these
people I show video evidence to prove it
yeah everything here's a fact that you
can ask you can ask yourself you have to
ask them I can't ask him right you don't
even have to ask him you ask yourself
because this I only deal in fact no
made-up [__] hey yo listen hoe average
you mean right y'all came about the
mother together he put you on he did
everything for you why why did you leave
him and take all those guns
why this is a reason fighting for his
life this is a ridiculous relief I can't
even there's no point in talking my
guy's dead so what are we even talking
about being dead
Kevin
when it made [__] with you so when he
came to the point with you where you say
some [__] like yo Ave is controversial I
don't know if I want to do I link the
[__] this guy's talking about he know
I'm the winner start all this [__] and
you having loyalty bro I'm telling you I
have no reason to lie whether I leave
without do this interview leaving now
I'm still gonna be rich bro I'm still
gonna be me I'm still gonna drop the
album and I'm still gonna go top 10 and
billboard I'm gonna do number one and
number two independent and I'm still
gonna live I'm still gonna be at the
floor seats on fights my life's still
gonna be good I'm telling you real life
[__] bro you don't even play my records
and it don't matter I'ma still be good
but I'm telling you just for Life moving
on be loyal and and truthful and hold it
down for the people that would really
hold it down for you and don't ask him
he's dead you can't but ask yourself why
wouldn't somebody do that these are the
facts why was Adam fighting for his life
in a room by himself things could have
turned out different so Mike why did you
have to get left to take all of these
guns you went unless the converse the
conversation
the conversations that you guys had
before he passed were you guys in a
positive place because you posted like a
rest in peace post Forum I mean yeah we
was cool but I'm gonna tell you what the
last conversation about the last
conversation we were supposed to get up
and he kind of Spun me like I've seen
him in person come here fat boy let's
talk [__] like you know what I'm saying
like because I saw your post and I was
like well [__] like I don't know I don't
know if this was the energy like it
seemed it was a positive post but like
if you had a lot of negative energy uh
towards no that's not true I I spoke I
spoke to him
we had a situation where we had to speak
about some business but because you guys
I mean look when you guys were like
[__] Damon and Hove you know what I'm
saying it was like Chili Avenue but I'm
saying like in terms of like yeah we was
like I never wouldn't be like no other
man but what I'm saying is
wait you can speak to somebody and [__]
two troops can be one
you they could have done all of this
[__] and you can still feel for
their loss that picture that I showed
you 100 that that video two things can
be true that that video that I put up
that's before rap [__] that's
freestyling and my mom's basement Studio
that I built and we counting my drug
money you hear me that I put them on to
go hey come on like I'm the type of
friendly yo I'm going buy these bricks
you can put in with me
no I don't want to put in I well I'll
get the bricks and whatever you sell
give me half but you got the opportunity
to come in and be a whole partner that's
before rap that's before anything that's
when you in Tampa not even know I
definitely agree with you you can you
can agree on two things can be true at
the same time right so you saying Were
you invited to the funeral
invited I found out first and I ain't no
people getting invited to funerals who
the [__] is invited to a funeral I've
never been invited to a funeral in my
life I mean I mean that's nuts to be
invited to a funeral yes you [__]
grieve me so I wouldn't invite nobody to
a funeral
you had to go to court that day right I
had to go to court that day but not even
that like
bro I found out hovine died before you
knew I actually I actually think I might
have found out I found out like the
night it happened I found out yeah I
found it the night before everybody
called me and we're like hey just so you
know it's happening
I got a call as well all right well then
there you go that's when I found out he
died yeah but you don't get invited to a
funeral at all you could just go I know
people that didn't even like mutual
friends of us that don't even
they didn't even speak to him whatever
they went to the funeral it ain't no
funeral was open invite when you lose
somebody like him does it make you like
kind of maybe want to patch some [__] up
with someone like Lido
[__] no I don't leave the bro for what
time is it tell me I'll be here one all
right well look the new new album is out
yeah new albums out there God is getting
the paper straight stand how often are
you dropping the podcast well every
every week we got episodes Roll With God
believe in God spread love and Destroy
hey that's the message to everybody
spread love and Destroy hate hate is a
cancer